[Music]
so right now it's it's really early
crude technology and it is impossible to
fully capture the full human experience
we can't yet inhabit someone else's body
we can't take a perspective from behind
their eyes we can get very close to that
but right now it's still a your head is
in the VR world and nothing else you're
able to look around but as we get more
hand tracking body tracking your body
will start to feel like it's in VR so
then how do we get to the point where we
can actually inhabit someone else's view
or a different species or a different
plant or even a solar system things that
were just not possible so I think right
now there is this limitation in just the
amount of throughput of pixels that you
can display on the screen we know we
need probably a hundred x the amount of
data flowing through our optic nerves to
get closer to how much information we're
taking in with our eyes in the real
world now we know that the audio has to
be far more fluid and far more tracked
to how we're moving our heads to have
that accurate spatial soundscape but
then you know even if all of those
things are real even if you're wearing a
full haptic suit and the touch was right
and the smell was right and maybe there
was a way to do taste you're not
actually feeling the emotion of someone
else that's not something that you can
inject but you can invoke it and this is
back to our natural ability to empathize
and you can look across species of
different animals and they exhibit
empathy it's something that's not unique
to us and it's something that you know
we can foster and cultivate we can train
we can improve it or we can be trained
not to use it we can be cold competitive
but there is this ability and it's
through years or thousands of years of
ancient wisdom from Eastern philosophies
and wisdom to cultivate our mind to be
able to
cultivate the most beneficial aspects of
what we're capable of doing and so if
we're able to put ourselves in
situations that require us to resonate
emotionally with someone else and then
require us to help and you could see
this as potentially in the future an
interactive layer in the experience in
which you can reach out you can pull a
remote and you're donating directly to
someone that is in need and so this
interactive experience in which you're
training yourself to emotionally
resonate training yourself to take an
action this will carry on within you in
your mind and your body after that
headset has been taken off so this
ability to I think improve ourselves to
become a more empathetic and
compassionate society is what I hope
you'll use is technology for
[Music]
you